that's something tremendously compelling
about watching world-class talent
reenact major moments in human history
whether they're playing gangsters Pope's
or Queens and thanks the Netflix many of
those very stories are available at the
push of a button
historical bio pics are often or lumped
into the same tonal category and when we
think of the genre we often think of
very ornate slightly stuffy costume
dramas with elaborate recreations of
famous faces them right though by pegs
can be the stuff of legend and that's
exactly what you get when you take some
time to watch it man the man of the
title is a legendary Chinese martial
artist best known in the West as a guy
who trained Bruce Lee in Wing Chun Kung
Fu the film follows up in the 1930s
during the sino-japanese war as he
attempts to keep himself alive so he can
protect his friends and feed his family
or facing Japanese oppression Donnie Yen
is graceful captivating and brilliant in
the title role playing it as a man
determined to contain his own martial
energy until the last possible moment
both for the sake of saving his own
strength and the safety of those around
him when he finally does explode into
pure martial arts mites it's absolutely
dazzling there's a reason yen has since
come back to star in three more up man
movies and that all starts right here in
2002 a writer named Julie Powell set out
to cook every recipe and mastering the
Art of French Cooking over the course of
a year while writing a blog about her
experience
the blog became a sensation and within a
few years Powell was a best-selling
author and her book was optioned for
film a film based on a cooking blog
seems like a questionable proposition
but that's where the great Nora Ephron
comes in in Efron's hands that Julie and
Julia becomes a merger of two stories
intercutting Powell's life experience
while starting and writing a blog with
Julia Child experiences in post-war
France that led her to become a chef
author and TV presenter
even if it isn't never apologize no
excuses no explanation by intertwining
the stories air phone makes Julie and
Julia not just the celebration of food
but a story of two women who somehow
find a way to save themselves from this
'less lives through the sense of purpose
that food culture gives them Amy Adams
and Meryl Streep are both tremendous in
their respective title roles and the
film is easily Efron's greatest visual
triumph sometimes the best approach for
a biopic is a comprehensive look at the
life of the person in question making
one film that spans decades at the time
some more focused approach is called for
drilling into a single important event
in a search for meaning humanity and
entertainment the end of the tour takes
the latter approach and it's an
extremely rewarding decision the film
centers on David Lipsky a Rolling Stone
writer who spent several days with
novelist David Foster Wallace in 1996 as
a latter was finishing up as Infinite
Jest tour the two men traveled together
talking about everything from the
virtues of junk food to addiction to
mental illness feeling so every action
your life turned out to be false and
there is actually nothing
and you are nothing there is relatively
narrow lens we get a compelling picture
of Wallace as a person and as a creator
without ever elevating him to mythic
status the end of the tour is a
beautifully crafted little road movie
and stars Jesse Eisenberg and Jason
Segel are working at the top of their
game the problem with making a movie
that's about the making of another movie
is our fans of the original film are
always going to react with skepticism
sure you're making of fictionalization
might be interesting but can it ever
possibly be as interesting as a film you
already know and love but hey man I put
on a girl what I got to do come on
brother they waiting on dolomite movie
let's bring dolomite to the screen
fortunately for everyone
dolomite is my name does not suffer from
this problem despite the tremendous
entertainment value that dolomite still
holds decades after his release Kraig
Buist film follows Rudy ray Moore a
struggling comedian who finds success
with a stage persona he borrowed from a
homeless man armed with new material and
a new sense of confidence more Desai's a
his character dolomite deserves his own
movie when conventional means of
filmmaking and financing fail him he
makes the foam
self what follows is a wonderfully
effective comedy that's also a
heartwarming story of determination
confidence and speaking or dreams out
into the world it's also the best work
Eddie Murphy's done in years if you only
know Martin Scorsese is a gangster movie
guy it might seem a little excessive of
him to make yet another crime drama this
late in his career especially one that
runs over three hours and makes heavy
use of digital D aging technology to
keep several of his favorite actors and
the whole thing but there are two things
wrong with that for one Scorsese is and
always has been more than just a
gangster filmmaker and for another the
Irishman is really really good what's
sad about based on the book I heard you
paint houses the film tells the story of
Frank Sheeran a low-level criminal who
rises through the ranks of the American
mob to such a degree that he developed a
friendship with infamous union leader
Jimmy Hoffa and ultimately plays a part
in Hoffa's disappearance the film
follows Sharon's rise through several
decades with all the visual diamond ISM
and emotional complexity we've come to
expect from Scorsese and by the end it's
a kind of epic summation of everything
he has to say about crime sin redemption
and more it's a long journey but it's
worth it when a film or television
series has a budget to swing it the
Vatican is a perfect place to stage a
cinematic story which helps explain the
allure of recent efforts like the young
Pope it's a visually gorgeous backdrop
but the headquarters of the Roman
Catholic Church also offers a sense of
deep intrigue that we can project all
manner of mysteries on be the mysteries
of faith or mysteries of pure human
frailty and in a true story and two
brilliant actors playing off each other
and you've got a can't-miss movie the
two popes as a fixture lights encounter
the meeting between the two most recent
pontiff's of the church benedict xvi and
francis when the former was a flagging
pope on his way out and the latter was a
cardinal considering retirement their
meeting seems fated that the
consequences of their conversation will
shake both of them as a church attempts
to whether one of the most tumultuous
storms in its recent history Anthony
Hopkins and Jonathan Pryce both received
Oscar nominations for their work in the
film and when you watch it you can see
why they're perfectly matched both doing
some of the best work of their careers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]